matt go ahead in new york i know i was
just wondering is there any bad blocks
between gary and jason
they're always like bickering and it
seems like ever since jason
found those plantain chips and gary's
drawer they just haven't been
the same
[Music]
yes i think you're right matt that they
do not like each other anymore because
both of them are smiling
uh i believe there is animosity or as
they say animos between the two
uh gary am i right come on this is what
i would say
jason and i really do like each other
but we do get on each other's nerves he
is very opinionated
and i know a lot of people gave me [ __ ]
for being the last one to figure out
that if jason has a chance he will throw
you under the bus you know for years i
would be like no
jason's good at least he'll tell you
about it and people and then and then
after he did to me a bunch of times i
was like oh yeah he kind of will [ __ ]
you over if you give me the chance
but that he feels that's his job so i'm
not gonna give him [ __ ] for it right
i will go on record to say two two
things can be true i love gary
uh truly and honestly uh like a second
father and i also get super annoyed by
him a lot
and super frustrated by him a lot and uh
that builds up and then boils over
based on what you just said do you feel
that when you
invaded his privacy opened up his drawer
and revealed his plantain chip
collection
yes was it an overstep an overview 100
not true the plantains were on his desk
at the door was open
and we worked in a live studio so but
did i say
jason did i did i say to you that day
don't go in my office
yeah you don't get to decide we're on a
live set brother live with it we all
work in an open office you have a camera
in there you have lights in there
you have plantain chips on your desk
you're falling asleep we have to see
what's going on
and there's you don't like it go work in
an office where we don't have a camera
in it
and this is the part where i go i give
up well gary
makes a point in other words it's a
radio show where you're one of the
players
uh he needs to inspect what's going on
in your office because he knows who
potentially could be a good bit on the
radio
and jason feels that comes first they
were a great bit
gary is very happy that we're in
quarantine and he no longer can be
inspected
well i know i know i know that gary
misses the whole point of the show
that's exactly why we want gary so we
can
inspect him and look at him during the
show and i am anxious to get back to uh
believe me i'm plenty inspected in this
house i get calls from
people there's plenty going on jimmy
from maryland what do you have to say
about this topic
hey now all i know is that [ __ ] jason
kaplan's voice goes through me like a
[ __ ] chainsaw he's the most annoying
[Laughter]